لقد التقينا لأول مرة في حرب الخليج الأولى
عندما كنت أنت نفسك مسؤولاً
عنا ، الصحافة لا أحد مسؤول
عنك جيدًا ، وكانت هناك
علاقة جيدة ، أم
جمال خاشقجي كان عضوًا في
الصحافة ، لقد كان سعوديًا وطنيًا.  أريد أن
أسألك ما هو رأيك عندما تسمع
الكلمات التالية من
المخابرات التركية ومن المخابرات الأخرى ،
نعلم أيضًا أن رئيس CI AG
في المستشفى قد سمع هذه
المعلومات الاستخباراتية في هذه الأشرطة حتى يذهب الناس
إلى السعوديين.  قنصلية
سنعيدك قالوا لخاشقجي إن
هذا أمر من الانتربول السعودي
يقول خاشقجي إن هناك ما يشير إلى عدم
وجود قضية ضدي ولم يكن الناس
ينتظرون بالخارج
ثم طلبوا منه كتابة رسالة نصية
إلى ابنه.  ثم يجادلون حول
ما سيقولونه ويقولون له قص الأمر ،
هناك صراع ما
رأيك عندما تسمع ذلك جيدًا ، دعني
أولاً أرد على سؤالك الأول
حول محاسبة الأشخاص الذين
يأتون  أوقف أبو غريب ولأن
قضيتنا في حالتنا ، فإن سبب
استمرار المحاكمات وسيعاقب الناس
فيما يتعلق برد الفعل
على الشريط الذي نعلم أن هذه عملية مارقة
لم يتم التصريح بها ، فنحن
نعلم أن جريمة ارتكبت لدينا
الناس في السجن وهم يخضعون للمحاكمة بينما
نتحدث ماذا تقول
لخاشقجي التالي يقول إن هناك منشفة
هنا ، هل ستعطيني مخدرات ،
يقولون أننا سنربطك ثم
هناك صراع ثم سألني رجل
حيث يُفقد خاشقجي
ثم يقول شخص آخر أو نفس الشخص أنه
يرفع رأسه ويقول آخر يقول
استمر في الدفع هنا لا ترفع يدك ،
ادفعها ، إنها جريمة شنيعة
حدثت خارج السلطات ومن
أجلها  إذا ارتكبت ذلك
فسوف تتم معاقبتهم ، ولهذا السبب توجد
محاكمة وهذا هو السبب في وجود تحقيق مستمر ما كان
يجب أن
يحدث
أبدًا.  ضع جذع
الجثة في كيس
رد آخر ، ليس ثقيلًا جدًا ، فليست
مشكلة الجسد ثقيل في المرة الأولى التي
أقطع فيها الأرض إذا أخذنا أكياسًا بلاستيكية وقمنا
بتقطيعها إلى قطع ،
فسوف ننتهي سنلف كل منها بشكل
رهيب  هذا أمر فظيع ،
لقد أخبرتك أن هذه جريمة قتل شنيعة
حدثت بدون إذن
ويتم معاقبة مرتكبيها الآن نحن
هناك في المحكمة هناك للمحاكمة
وسيتم معاقبتهم ، لقد أوضحنا ذلك
تمامًا.